[Music]
all right let's just talk about it
blue bubbles versus green bubbles now
right off the top most of this is going
to sound pretty ridiculous to the 70 of
you that are watching this outside of
the u.s mostly because it seems like
every other country sort of just points
and laughs at the blue bubble versus
green bubble situation in the united
states because pretty much everywhere
else the iphone isn't nearly as dominant
but we will talk about what some other
countries are doing in a second we'll
get to that but for now
here
it's a big deal and you'll see why
so let's go back in time originally if
you wanted to send someone a text
message how did you do it
well back in the day as early as 1992
you just get their phone number and you
send them an sms it's pretty simple sms
stands for short messaging service it's
attached to your phone number it's 160
bytes max per message every phone has an
sms app easy send your text now of
course that was super simple and if
you're old enough like me you remember
if you had a long enough message you had
to spread it out over two texts because
you hit the character limit eventually
we wanted to do a little bit more with
our messages maybe some emojis some
pictures something like that once in a
while and so we added mms so mms stands
for multimedia messaging service it's
built on the same technology as sms you
can send anything over 160 bytes and
this came around in about 2002. so a
single mms message could be up to a
couple hundred kilobytes or so and so
these two combined basically blew up
with the adoption of the smartphone so
now we've got phones everywhere people
send in text messages emojis pictures
everything back and forth and they sort
of ramped up in popularity from there
and every phone has a default messaging
app including the most notorious of them
all the iphone which has one with this
icon
that's the messages app so now messages
works fine with iphones and everybody's
texting just like normal but eventually
we got up again to the limit of what we
were able to do with sms and mms our
communications get even more rich we
want to send larger image files back and
forth it's it's it's advanced we're
getting better at this whole texting
thing right so apple announces imessage
in 2011 which is an instant messaging
service that's built right into the
messages app now imessage works over the
internet and has a ton of advantages
over sms and mms there's now typing
indicators you can send quick reactions
to messages files have this new massive
hundred megabyte file size limit so you
can send crispy high resolution pictures
or pdfs or videos even there's read
receipts inline replies location sharing
there's just a ton of features and most
importantly
it's now end to end encrypted which
makes it much more secure than sms ever
was and then since it works over the
internet it syncs up with all of your
internet connected apple devices the
phone but also the mac and the apple
watch and your ipad whatever else you
got but in classic apple fashion it is
not multi-platform so there is no
imessage for windows there is no
imessage for android
now the key here to the blue bubble
versus green bubble war is that
most people
in the u.s
just use the default messaging app that
comes with their device like i know here
on the mkbhd channel we're all tech
savvy and we know about the other
messaging apps that we prefer that have
more features and things like that but
most people
just use
the default
app
for everything on their device actually
the default browser the default email
app and the default
messaging app so when an iphone user
goes to message someone first thing they
do is open up the messages app and if
the person that they're messaging is
also on an iphone immediately boom it
gets converted into an imessage so you
get the read receipts the reactions the
encryption all the features
blue bubbles now when an iphone user
goes to message someone that doesn't
have imessage well it still needs to get
to them somehow and so the iphone
defaults back to sending it via sms
the old super limited standard so
no read receipts no typing indicators no
reactions and definitely no encryption
and you for sure know when the person
you're texting doesn't have imessage
because you get those nice green bubbles
and it's actually a little bit worse
than just not having the features
because now if the iphone user tries to
like the text
it still has to get that information to
the android user somehow and so it
defaults by sending that via sms2 it
just sends a text to the android phone
saying
marquez liked your text which is just
kind of brutal and worse yet if you try
to send a video it still has to get that
information to you somehow so it
defaults to mms which is super
compressed into oblivion because of that
max file size have you ever seen a video
that gets sent between an android phone
and an iphone like a totally normal
looking smooth 1080p video shows up as
like a dumpster fire about 100 pixels
wide when texting between iphone and
android it's kind of unbelievable in
this high-tech world we live in that
this is still so bad and the list just
keeps going and going like if you're in
a group chat too
you can forget about it like i don't
know if you've ever seen a group chat on
an iphone in the messages app that mixes
iphones and sms
it's bad like if three people react to
one message it creates three new text
messages you can't add people to that
group there's no inline replies in those
group chats it's genuinely bad basically
the green bubble experience on an iphone
is
trash and apple
well apple
is actually fine with this
[Music]
because like i said this is all driven
by people using the default messaging
app that comes on their phone and the
spice that just gets sprinkled on top of
all this is that the iphone is
incredibly popular
in this country like i think we already
knew that the iphone was pretty popular
but i don't know if you realize how
popular the iphone is here like if you
had to guess what percentage of 18 to 24
year olds would you say use an iphone in
the us to make it dominant like 20 30
maybe
maybe over half over 50
yeah try
70
of 18 to 24 year olds in the u.s seven
out of every 10
young adults and college students here
are carrying an iphone so apple's a
three trillion dollar company for a
reason they're really good at compelling
people to use their products and once
you start they're good at building the
walls up around you as high as possible
so you never really want to leave i made
an entire video about the apple
ecosystem what it is
why it works i'll link that explained
video below but the bottom line is it's
more than just
neat hardware products that can act as
walls in the walled garden around that
ecosystem so we already knew about the
apple watch only working with the iphone
you already knew about airpods being
great with the iphone and air tags but
turns out software can be those walls
too
and imessage is a really big wall so
switching to
an android phone
would mean not just losing the imessage
features and becoming a green bubble but
also apple's created such a social
network of iphone users using iphone
only features to communicate with each
other that android users actually feel
genuinely ostracized and left out nobody
wants that so think about it if 70 of
young people around you own an iphone
and imessage is the default and it's
good for groups and social dynamics yeah
most new people are just going to use
that too and if most people use it it
makes the people who don't have iphones
feel left out their default is
definitely a worse texting experience
and being left out of group chats and so
it just puts even more real pressure on
those people to just get with it just
get it over with get an iphone and then
the cycle continues it's a
self-fulfilling prophecy so no matter
what you think of those pressures or how
crazy you think that sounds that is real
and that is often what's being referred
to when we say imessage lock-in imessage
is genuinely one of the biggest walls in
apple's walled garden that they've
created and it's a particularly hot
topic even right now as i'm recording
this but also i feel like every year
there's some you know expose about how
we're all learning about people getting
bullied for not having iphones or those
stories about how people on tinder get
statistically less dates after
exchanging phone numbers when it's
revealed that they're a green bubble
it's crazy but this is a conversation
that's been going on since imessage came
out and it's been getting louder and
louder as more and more people get
iphone
so
what's the solution to this well if
you're new here you might say
oh well just bring imessage
to android that way everybody has
everything
uh and yeah that's that's never gonna
happen i mean it's a good idea i like
the way you're thinking but never gonna
happen i'd give that the same odds as
the new york knicks winning the 2022 nba
championship
technically possible but i wouldn't get
your hopes up now fun fact there was
actually a movement within apple back in
2013 where apparently it came up in a
few meetings legal documents around the
apple versus epic court case had eddie q
testify that apple could have made a
version of imessage on android but
apparently craig federighi and phil
schiller jumped in noting that it would
quote simply serve to remove an obstacle
to iphone families giving their kids
android phones and moving imessage to
android will hurt us more than help us
so basically it's crystal clear that
apple higher ups recognize the value of
imessage lock-in
so that's not going anywhere there's no
plans to bring imessage to android so
the natural next thought is okay what if
what if there was a single
multi-platform messaging app that
everyone could use if it can't be
imessaged someone else can make one and
then everyone can use that i mean this
is probably already what you're seeing
down in the comments section from
thousands of people who didn't make it
this far in the video saying hey we'll
just use whatsapp or telegram and so to
all those comments yeah it would be
great if everyone could just have one
multi-platform app that everyone uses
and we could all get along and have
windows and apple devices and android
devices all having read receipts and
reactions and typing and all that stuff
yeah that would be pretty cool right but
there's two main problems in the way of
that
one is that people are still like i
mentioned earlier overwhelmingly
predisposed to using the default
messaging app that comes with their
device so having everyone decide to use
whatsapp for example involves a bunch of
extra steps for all the devices where
that's not the default
including the iphone and then you have
to go out and get your entire social
circle to also make that switch
to use that new default app like you
know how hard it is to convince everyone
you talk to to switch defaults actually
in some countries whatsapp basically is
a default at this point but imagine
trying to get everyone in the us to also
switch their default to something
different it's just have you ever tried
to get your parents to switch default
apps on something it's impossible and
then two even if you did convince the
whole world successfully to use this one
golden multi-platform messaging app
is it really a good idea to have the
entire planet's messaging in the hands
of one company
and should that one company be meta of
all companies is that really a good idea
whatsapp right now is the most popular
multi-platform messaging app on the
planet there are two billion monthly
active users on whatsapp it's super
popular in india lots of businesses
there use it too i don't know if you
remember but when facebook or meta went
down for a couple hours in october of
last year all of their services
basically went dark and people
communities businesses that depended on
whatsapp all had to shut down for hours
because they couldn't communicate or do
business or anything at all matter of
fact there was a headline that telegram
in those six hours gained 70 million
users because of how many people needed
to communicate but couldn't when
whatsapp was down now the next most
popular app is facebook messenger also
by meta that's 1.3 billion people but
then underneath that wechat and then qq
both extremely popular in china another
option is telegram but you see where
we're going here there is no universal
one golden ticket and they're all of
course owned by some company and
optimists might think well maybe google
is in the best position
to make the perfect all-in-one
multi-platform messaging app because
they make android
but a realist would probably noticed
that they've tried this
many
many
many many times by now
all of them unsuccessful this could
probably be a whole topic for a whole
nother video but yeah bottom line is
even if you are cool with one company
handling everything it's basically
impossible to get everyone
from every place using one single app
like i mean i would love my entire you
know community people around me
teammates friends family to all use
discord but that's
probably not going to happen it's both
an upside and a downside that there's a
fragmentation of messaging services it's
a downside because we're not all
universally using the same thing but
it's a good thing because there is still
competition but hey there's also
one
more
option
three letters
rcs
[Music]
okay so we already broke down how we saw
messaging get started with texts and sms
and then mms turns out there's a new
messaging standard that was first
implemented in like 2018
called rcs rich communication service so
rcs is a pretty obvious next step for
smartphone manufacturers to support over
the next couple years and it's another
evolution of messaging features and it
supports a ton of that stuff read
receipts typing indicators reactions to
messages much larger file support google
added rcs support into the default
google messages app which it's trying to
make basically the default messaging app
on every android phone coming out and at
this point it's pretty hard to get a new
phone out the box that doesn't ship with
rcs support in 2022. they've all got it
well
all of them except
the iphone so in this war of blue bubble
imessage perfection versus green bubble
sms
madness it seems like the best possible
solution that we've got the one that
makes the most sense is for apple to
build rcs support
into imessage it just makes a lot of
sense right but the way that standards
work is kind of funny so as we said
earlier they shouldn't really ever be
controlled by one company so rcs itself
is a set of standards developed by gsma
it can work in a decentralized manner
which means there are actually several
different rcs implementations so
theoretically any company with the right
hardware and enough servers could spin
up their own version if they wanted to
some carriers have spun up their own
implementations in the past but really
the most important one the one to pay
the most attention to
is the universal profile which has all
the same you know all the big core
features but also works with as many
different versions as possible so google
comes along
and they build what's called google chat
which is their own implementation of rcs
using the universal profile so it's got
all the same core features and
everything bigger file sizes reactions
read receipts and all that
but now it's running on google's own
jibe servers
and it's not actually built directly
into the core of android for some reason
but it is supported directly by google's
messages app which like we see they're
trying to make that the default
messaging app on google android phones
so the version of rcs the flavor of rcs
that most people will experience turns
out is actually google's version
so from apple's perspective
basically it's like all right we made
imessage right so imessage is a service
we made
that runs on our servers on the app that
we made on the phones that we made
and rcs
is a service that google worked on that
runs on google servers
that works in a google app
on android phones
so it's kind of their
it's another google messaging app really
although the most successful one yet so
we're not really sure what google
which is an advertising company
is going to do with rcs as they continue
to develop it if they have plans to
monetize it at all we don't know that so
to apple it's like well hey hey if it's
just another google messaging service we
already built the better mousetrap
imessage
so here's my take and it's a pretty
simple one really
even though there's gonna be this
pressure of blue bubbles versus green
bubbles that's not anything we can
control but apple should add rcs support
to imessage there's just no downside at
all right now now
currently you know the way apple moves
so slow to adopt new things until
absolutely positively sure about it
there's almost no chance that they
actually do this but they totally should
and look it's not a perfect solution at
all because there is none you know rcs
doesn't cover every single little
feature of imessage it doesn't have an
emoji there's no support for the apps
and games that they've built into
imessage and apple pay payments and
there's only end-to-end encryption right
now on one-to-one chats not for group
messages but it is a ton of the most
basic most important ones the read
receipts the larger file sizes the
reactions the quick oh group messages
would be dramatically better you could
actually leave a group chat or add new
people to it if it just had rcs support
everyone could have all these things
working and most importantly of all
especially for apple it supports
end-to-end encryption
for direct messages
and for a company that swears up and
down that they care about your privacy
and your security you think it would be
the easiest decision in the world to
stop sending iphone users messages over
an old
unsafe unencrypted sms standard
and just support the one that's new that
is more secure but given what we know
about these companies
every day that apple doesn't add rcs
support to imessage they're sending a
subtle hint
a subtle message that they value
that lock in just a little bit more so
look the colors of the bubbles at this
point have become a bit of a meme it's a
little overly played out yes there are
people that take it super seriously and
there's no doubt in my mind that apple
does think about the aesthetics of the
colors to dissuade people from green a
little bit fun fact the contrast ratio
of the green with the white text
actually breaks some of apple's own
rules about what you can do in apps i'll
leave a link below so you can read about
that but for those wondering the actual
original story about why it's blue
versus green and it was hard to find a
source on this but i'll try my best is
that green was supposed to represent a
paid message when blue was not if it was
an sms you were paying the carrier for
it and necessarily giving money while
blue was just possibly over the internet
or wi-fi so free green paid blue free
but that's that's almost like a
backstory at this point apple's a very
smart company with lots of very smart
people
who are in charge of making sure they
stay in as much control and as much
power as they possibly can and they know
that the difference between the blue
bubble experience and the green bubble
experience is so strong
that it's enough to send real pressure
for people to switch to the iphone who
aren't on it and for people to stay on
the iphone who are
and that's good enough for them
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace